all right what's the question sir I've
been watching you for a while Sam I love
you oh man I'm sorry to hear that be and
I love me too
sir so I my question is um so when Jesus
died on the cross you know our Lord yes
for three days what did like what
happened like for three days you got to
be more specific what do you mean like
where you go for three days oh you're
talking about when Jesus's human Spirit
Soul left his body which was still
inseparably United to the logos the one
Divine person who now took on human
nature physical body human soul well the
belief from scripture and the early
churches he went to the Underworld the
Nether world the realm of the Dead to
Abraham's
bsom I can show you verses on that if
you want but is there some more specific
so I can answer it more
thoroughly not really that's that's
probably so do you want the verses to
show where Jesus descended to the
underworld the Nether
world okay now Al you there yeah no not
Al ALB okay now can you read Luke
26-31 now he wants to know what proof do
we have that Jesus descended into the
realm of the Dead during the three days
his body lay in the Tomb all right then
they seed
to the country of the uh gin gines
whatever it is
Garin which is opposite uh Galilee and
when he stepped out on the Land There
met him a certain man from the city who
had demons for a long time and he wore
no clothes nor did he live in a house
but in the tombs when he saw Jesus he
cried out fell down before him and with
a loud voice said what have I to do with
you Jesus Son of the most high God I beg
you do not torment me for he had
commanded the unclean Spirit to come out
of the man for it had often seized him
and he was kept under guard bound with
chains and shackles and he broke the
bonds and was driven by the demon Into
the
Wilderness Jesus asked him saying what
is your name and he said Legion because
many demons had entered him all right
keep
and they and they begged him that he
would not command them to go out into
the abyss now a heard of many swine was
feeding there on the mountain so They
begged him that he would permit them to
enter them and he permitted that 31 said
what said and They begged him that he
would not command them to go out into
the abyss now did you hear that word
brother super yeah the abyss the the
abuso also called the bottomless pit
right mhm okay now you're going to see
where the abuso the bottomless pit
refers to because that's where demons
are imprisoned and chained guys notice
the demons do not want to go to the
abyss listen guys to this important the
word abuso also is bottomless pit they
don't want to go there because that's
where demons are sent and are impr
prison and chained that's where Satan
will be chained for a thousand years
Revelation 20 verses 1 or3 GNA read for
Revelation 20 verse1
and3 thank you swins and Gina B yeah
really good then I saw an angel coming
down from heaven having the key to the
bottomless pit and a great chain in his
hand he laid hold of the dragon that
Serpent of old who is the devil and
Satan and bound him for a thousand years
and he cast him into the bottomless pit
the word bottomless pit is the abyss
it's the same word guys if you look at
the Greek that word bottoms Smith is the
same word the abyss that the demons not
want to go to
right okay keep
reading so that he should deceive the
and he cast him into the abyss and shut
him up and set a seal on him so that he
should not deceive the Nations no more
till the thousand years were finished
but after these things he must be
released for a little while now when you
get a chance guys all of you read
Revelation chapter 9 its entirety for
the sake of time we won't read it so
Abyss bottomless pit Luke 8:31
Revelation 20 verses 1 to three
Revelation n that's the place where
demons are in chained in prison that's
where Satan will be in
prison Jesus for those three days
descended into the abyss the bottomless
ple to the realm of the Dead to Hades
shol because now go to Romans 10 6-7
Romans 10 6-7 watch this where did Jesus
come up from when he was raised on the
third day Romans 10:
6-7 but the righteousness of Faith
speaks in this way do not say in your
heart who will Ascend into heaven that
is to bring Christ down from above or
who will descend into the abyss that is
to bring Christ up so where did he go do
you see in Romans 10 6-7 it says
bring Christ up from the abyss so on the
third day Jesus came up from where the
abyss
right everyone seeing
it and this guy said shol no it did not
say shol in that verse pretend you guys
are listening now when Albi comes back
from the Rapture he's going to look at
Acts 2 29- 32 to show you that on the
third day Jesus came out of Hades
Hades so for the three days Jesus
descended into the Underworld the
underworld where you have Hades where
you have the abyss Abraham's bosom
that's where he was so read acts
okay men and Brethren let me speak
freely to you of the patriarch David
that he is both dead dead and buried and
his tomb is with us to this day
therefore being a prophet and knowing
that God has sworn with o to him that of
the fruit of his body according to the
flesh he would raise up the Christ to
sit on his throne he foreseeing this
spoke concerning the resurrection of the
Christ that his soul was not left in
Hades did you guys catch it his soul
Jesus's soul that left his body was not
left in Hades because it returned to his
body and he was raised on the third day
so keep reading acts
23132 nor did hish see
corruption this Jesus God has raised up
of which we are all Witnesses okay now
you guys caught it Romans 10 veres 6 to7
Jesus came up from the abyss Luke 8:31
Revelation 20 verses 1-3 Revelation 9
the abyss the abuso bottomless pit is
where demons Satan is bound
they're
debound acts
22932 Jesus's soul went to Hades sh
where his flesh was in the Tomb his soul
came up from the abyss from Hades
entered his body and was resurrected
this where the early church got the
teaching that Jesus went to hell meaning
Hades shol the abyss but he didn't go
there to be tormented he didn't go there
to be tortured that's blasphemy if
anyone tells you Jesus went there to be
tortured they are blasphemers he went
there to proclaim the Victory and that
the promises have been fulfilled and he
went there to take out Abraham and all
the righteous who are in Abraham's bsom
resting where others were tormented to
take their souls into heaven to be with
the father that's the teaching